eine Freundin hat mit tiktok Videos
rausgesucht auf die ich in einem Youtube
Video reagieren sollte deswegen würde
ich sagen starten wir direkt mit dem
ersten Video
[Musik]
nein ich will eigentlich gar nicht
lachen
[Musik]
doch die härterin kommt auf die
Gärtnerin
ich weiß wieder warum ich so lange nicht
auf tiktoks reagiert habe
[Musik]
das bin ich und ich sag euch jetzt noch
eine Sache die euer komplettes Leben
verändern wird ihr braucht nur einen
Löffel
scheiß Aufgabe scheiß auf besser du
brauchst nur ein Löffel
[Musik]
oh mein Gott
ich habe mich lange nicht mehr so
erschrocken
größter Abturner
wenn eine Person beim Lachen plötzlich
zu einem Schwein mutiert
noch ein größerer abteiler ist
vielleicht in no Front ich liebe
Österreich aber dieser Akzent dieses
sakritz
was für rechts ab
mhm
Sitze im Stuhl sowie Hockey
er warum eine Katze
ja hasse Katzen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
komm weiter mit dir
[Musik]
das ganz genau warum wir dieses Video
ausgesucht wurde ich habe mich letztens
im Park unfassbar
peinlich auf die Fresse gelegt als ich
mich auf den Ball drauf stellen wollte
mitten im grünen Gürtel in Köln aber ich
zeige ich habe was gelernt
[Musik]
das Video wird safe
mit Absicht direkt hinter diese krassen
Brasilianer gepackt um zu zeigen hey
guck mal und das ist dann Luca
und das ist nämlich Cybermobbing
und das wird zur Anzeige gebracht
junge willst du mich verarschen du
kleiner Hut an der Stelle ganz liebe
Grüße an selfie Sandra egal es war nur
einmal
da war kein Ton und wurde wegen
urheberrechtsbeschränkung entfernt
okay müssen wir uns glaube ich dann noch
mal angucken es ist 5 Uhr morgens guck
[Musik]
Luisa
hier sind Mücken ganz Nacht die denken
diesen bei mir willkommen ich mag keinen
Besuch ihr seid herzlich nicht
eingeladen
was
ja wie ihr brecht den Mädel Urlaub nach
vier Tagen ab weil ihr euch alle
gestritten habt und nicht mehr
miteinander befreundet seid
warum sind Frauen so
[Musik]
irgendwie ich hätte letztens von anderen
Frauen auch gehört immer in diesem
mädelsurlaub hat man irgendwie Stress hä
also ich habe mir das Video gerade
sechsmal hintereinander angeguckt
der gefragt hat ja
okay das ist Harry style ich kann euch
ganz genau sagen warum der da drin ist
die Freundin die mir das rausgesucht hat
ist der riesigste Harry Styles Fan der
Welt wirklich ich kann diese Milchtüte
nicht so ganz verstehen klar kann gut
singen aber das ist dieses geben das
heißt nicht dass er schlechte Musik war
nicht dass es wieder hier auch als ich
damals the weekend war gesagt habe dass
ich auch kein weekend Fame das heißt
auch nicht dass der schlechte Musik
machen bitte hatet mich jetzt nicht aber
ich kann jetzt schon mal sagen in diesem
Video wird absolut nichts passieren wir
schauen weiter
gemacht
oh shit
[Applaus]
oh mein Gott ich habe letztens bekommen
weil ich so ein wirklich also so ein
minimalen Rest nicht eingepuppert habe
vom Sohn Brokkoli immer dann so ein Buch
drüber damit die Person das dann nicht
sieht wir haben alle das gleiche leben
ja keine Ahnung hat mir das jetzt sagen
sollte wir machen weiter ich habe um 8
Uhr morgens nichts besseres zu tun
als diese Einkaufswagen hier rauszuholen
warum macht man das und das auch noch
dreimal korrekt danke
[Musik]
ich weiß ganz genau warum jedes einzelne
Video hier drin ist
nein ich werde nicht nach Australien
fliegen dieses Land kann mir wirklich
gestohlen bleiben ich hasse Schlangen
ich und Australien ist voll damit es ist
ein unnormal langer Flug und ich habe
auch ein bisschen Respekt vom Fliegen
und da ist ja nix da ist nichts was mich
interessiert außer vielleicht dieses
Sydney Opa das ist das einzige was ich
da kennen und auch da schaut einfach
niemanden hinter die Oper dicker das
sieht aus wie Köln kalt da brennen Bäume
einfach aus nichts weil er die
Ozonschicht zuschauen ich kann es nicht
verstehen
[Musik]